foreign  [Music]  they were seeing off their son and  daughter-in-law she says they went  outside to wave goodbye and they were  killed their house was also destroyed  [Music]  thank you  foreign  [Music]  months of Russian occupation has  obliterated any semblance of a normal  life for people here but what ukrainians  have shown time and again  is that they'll do anything to help each  other  [Music]  foreign  Bridge Ukraine denies blowing up two  months ago this morning Ukraine is also  denying being responsible for those  attacks deep inside Russian territory  only saying that such incidences are and  I'm quoting here karma for Russia's  invasion